the us army has gone totally woke
as well we played a couple of weeks ago
a cia recruitment ad about some woman
talking about i'm proud i'm brilliant
i'm a latina
woman feminist intersectional and just
this woke insanity it made me
want to just abolish the cia the first
chance i possibly can
but unfortunately now the army is
following suit
this is the story of a soldier who
operates your nation's patriot missile
defense
systems
it begins in california with a little
girl
raised by two moms although i had a
fairly typical childhood
took ballet played violin
i also marched for equality i like to
think i've been defending freedom from
an early age
i finished high school at the top of my
class and then attended uc davis
where i joined a sorority full of other
strong women
but as graduation approached i began
feeling like i'd been handed so much in
life
a sorority girl stereotype i needed my
own adventures my own challenge
and after meeting with an army recruiter
i found it
a way to prove my inner strength and
maybe shatter some stereotypes
along the way
[Music]
i'm us army corporal emma malone lord
and i answered my calling
huh so when i was a kid i'm gonna this
is gonna date me go way back
the army recruitment ads were a bunch of
tough guys jumping out of airplanes and
shooting guns and stuff like that
and the slogan was be all that you can
be
and it was like really tough guys and
now now the army recruitment ads
are about how lesbians on santa monica
pier
raised a ballerina who then joined the
army later
and and and what is she
like what's she do what's the what's the
mission what's that doesn't it's just
the identity is the mission
you see here the sh i'm not surprised
that the the army and the cia
are doing this i mean these are
defenders of the establishment if if
anything
is a defender of the establishment
surely it would be the military and the
intelligence communities right the
national security state
and the establishment at this point has
totally gone woke it's totally delved
into identity
and there's this shift this is actually
i'm going to totally hit the the plug
counter again today
because this is this is a shift that i
detail in my upcoming book speechless
which is that under political
in under the old moral order what
matters most is what you
do under the new political correctness
code
what matters most is what you say all
the language we use all the
woke jargon under the
old moral order we found our identity
in god right god who says i am that i
am right that's that the essence of
being we find our identity out there
so we don't think about ourselves very
much under the new
woke leftist moral order all we
ever think about is who we are all we
ever think about
is our own identity
my priest father george rutler famously
said
that when you lose your identity
in the i am when you when you divorce
your identity
from the i am you're left with a pitiful
question which is who am i
and you see this mostly on the left i'm
black i'm a woman i'm a lesbian i'm a
bi poc transgender they him bishop
lutheran whatever
and but you see it in some identitarians
on the right i'm white or i'm
nordic or i'm this or i'm that or i'm
this or i'm that
all of that though is such a shift from
the old idea and you see it so clearly
in the army because the point of the art
you know what the point of the army is
kill our enemies that's the point kill
and
deter by killing deter the other ones
people who want to harm us but now that
shift of
doing is totally that their sense of
doing is totally gone
all of the recruitment for the cia as
well is
who i am what i can who i am who i'm
going to be in my identity in my mind
not what i'm actually doing but in
my mind in my mind i can
make a hell of heaven or heaven to hell
is what uh what satan said in paradise
lost and
we're starting to see it all around us
nope not so fast you know you know what
you got to do
come on don't make me say it you got to
ring the bell
you got to ring the bell you got to
subscribe you got to like that is how
you will get notifications so that i can
see you on the next
[Music]
[Music]
video